you smell you smell unique
that does not sound like a compliment it
could be
[Music]
now let me ask you ben schwartz yes
mitzi lovely to see you it's so lovely
to have a conversation with you yeah
because for me comedians are king and
queen court gesture they're the whole
thing oh great the whole enchilada
that's so nice you know i don't care if
it's physical or emotional ailment the
one tap
i go to
comedy why is comedy so important
can i stop you for one second it makes
me feel like when you get a drink of
water you go right on because you did it
you went right under the tap and you
opened your mouth is that how you drink
your water
when i can okay so you're like old
school you go right under that tap get a
little metallic in that mouth i'm not
opposed to keg stance or just getting
right there
yeah hi lord yeah i'm on the tap i'm on
the feeder like a rat
you know they get that little ball in
the water
this is unbelievable they keep going
they keep drinking that's me with comedy
why is comedy so important to you i love
making people laugh oh you do i love oh
my goodness i love the idea of making
people i love the idea of someone coming
into a theater that i'm performing in
and then all of a sudden if their day is
kind of crappy they can forget
everything we can enjoy someone together
they laugh and they leave a little bit
happier than when they came in
you're getting hot that's sexy though
yeah
do you find this sexy it to me it feels
like compression socks it feels like you
might have hurt your foot or your ankle
and i wasn't sure if i was allowed to
talk about it did you hurt yourself did
you fall or no i did i rolled my ankle
on the new york city sidewalk in typical
new york fashion house nobody stopped
nobody stopped no they just walked were
you doing were you on your phone or were
you no no i was just walking yeah i had
my two dogs off leash oh those are their
names off and leash well i don't believe
in leashes okay
not on dogs at least wolf excuse me you
heard me
by the way i heard your favorite cookie
is the black and white i love a black
and white cookie well i just so happen
to have some black and white cookies for
you right here i got just right there
yeah because you just landed off a plane
i did i just got here oh i know mitzi
for this and what i like to do is i like
to eat one of them first and save
usually the chocolate for last so try to
get in the middle well i'm going to go
right here like this
i have a feeling if this goes well i
have a feeling we're going to be lady
and tramping that [ __ ] by the end of
this if this interview goes well
it's really too
hard
soon
there's something about you man
i don't know is there something about
you that makes
god you're sweating your eyes are
bleeding
do i have any chocolate on my mouth
i wish what are the common themes that
keeps coming up hard right turn we went
right back to questions when i
research you is
you like your mom i love my mom i love
my parents are you a mommy's boy i think
so i think my mom and my dad we have a
very close family my mom my dad my
sister were very close i like it i like
a mommy's boy i like it i think that's a
compliment i don't mean that as an
insult
you know who i else also have a the
hearts for letterman and and you wrote
oh yes you wrote jokes for letterman i
freelance jokes for letterman woof yeah
freelance jokes for letterman yeah i did
freelance jokes for letterman uh-huh
yeah tell me about it so what i use i
used to it's facts and jokes so i bought
a fax machine you do you know you moved
up a little bit wait a minute you work
on facts i worked on facts i work
exclusively on facts it's a very elite
club is that true yeah oh my goodness
yeah so i bought a fax machine that
would write jokes and fax them in i had
to pay for a landline and all that stuff
i like that
i like dialing a number you know what i
mean
what's it about dialing a number because
you're kicking it old school don't even
tell me you got a globe in there i got a
globe in the house
when i want to figure out where i want
to go on vacation i spin that
how have you been on my life i have what
she's having oh wait you also wrote
jokes for saturday night live freelance
wrote for uh saturn live i would facts
and jokes for them as well god you're
getting you're sweating you're literally
sweating i'm just i'm excited about the
jokes i love snl i like letterman i like
faxes and globes you're pushing all my
buttons what i'm going to do now to it's
to uh close up this amazing this was
unbelievable i know let me get
professional do you have a cell phone by
the way you probably don't have a cell
phone right
over fax me
you want me to fax you i want you to fax
me so hard
that it's not even funny listen
it's the faucet it's the spit take time
all right now
surprisingly you try it you just
and you don't lose tradition
okay you're getting are you filling it
up oh here we go to do a spit take what
should we talk about start a
conversation beforehand
got no water left
okay
let's say we fax just nod yes or no the
spectator's gonna come at the end
what kind of things would you want me to
fax you right
you want me to fax you like
no no no no no wait wait
you wait what kind of things you want me
to fax you huh don't think about you
falling down think about the rain coming
down think about your dogs running away
it was the dogs that was not tantric i
can last longer than that i don't know
mitch trust
trust yeah okay
well this has been an honor and a
privilege mitzi bananamore here with ben
schwartz is that your real name that is
my last name yeah well that's rax um and
yes this is my real last name it's been
an honor when you're born with a name
like banana more and you don't end up in
comedy something went wrong you know
yeah well what did your parents do
welders
thank you we'll be uh back with uh yeah
whatever bye
[Music]